und von im new yorker schauen wir nach
new york dort besteht nämlich die angst
vor den haien mindestens sechs menschen
sind an der atlantikküste von 1
angegriffen worden es ist die wohl
größte angst im meer
aus den tiefen des wassers aus dem
nichts ein hai
nichts ein heim auf
long island halbinsel im atlantik und
beliebtes urlaubsziel für die new yorker
wird diese angst jetzt war
die herrlichen strände an long island
sind
naherholungsgebiet für millionen new
yorker besonders während dieses extrem
heißen sommers allerdings dieses jahr
grassiert die angst an den sandstränden
von langweilen
innerhalb weniger wochen werden sechs
menschen an der küste long island opfer
eines hai angriff anwalt schauen
donnelley ist einer von ihnen herbert
bauernebel trifft den leidenschaftlichen
surfer zwei wochen nach der attacke am
ort des geschehens
es war wie jeder andere morgen auch ich
ging vor der arbeit surfen war für 20
minuten im wasser bereitete mich auf die
nächste welle vor und auf einmal
etwas wird mich vom brett der hai beißt
mich und weiß in mein surfbrett als ich
vom brett gefallen bin ich sogar die
hilflose hinter
und kämpft sich zurück auf sein
surfbrett rettet sich mit der nächsten
welle zurück ans land in sicherheit erst
dann bemerkt scheint die wunde an seiner
wade ein hai biss von anlagen wird die
rettungskräfte diese bringen ihn ins
krankenhaus
der 41 jährige kommt mit einer bisswunde
und einem schock davon
es war furchtbar es war wirklich das
schlimmste was mir im leben passiert ist
auch auf namen wie diesel sorgen an der
küste long islands für entsetzen ein
weißer hai tod an den strand gespült er
ist mehr als zwei meter lang die augen
und das maul weit aufgerissen nur einen
tag vorher dieses unfassbare video
einheit springt vor dem stadtteil queens
aus dem wasser und verschwindet zurück
im wasser es seither herrscht hier am
strand doch eine gewisse angespanntheit
man sieht einige menschen die hinaus
blicken aufs meer versuchen doch die
berühmte heckflosse eines fisches zu
sehen
urlauberin carey fährt seit jahren mit
ihrer familie nach long island liebt es
im atlantik zu schwimmen doch jetzt
nicht mehr
angst vor haien ich dachte die sind eh
weit weg aber momentan bin ich viel
besorgter meine freunde und familie
augen wie alle denken was passiert wenn
man zu weit im wasser
dass menschen haie in der nähe der küste
sichten ist kein einzelfall doch dieses
jahr ist es besonders dramatisch dass
erhöhte hypercom ist eigentlich ein
erfolg zumindest für die meere experten
meinen dass der grund für die vielen
haifisch sichtungen oder attacken
eigentlich ein guter ist nehmen die was
gewässer sind sauberer geworden hier vor
langweilen es gibt mehr fischbestände
und die locken natürlich auch haifische
an hai-alarm vor der atlantikküste gut
für das meeresleben schlecht für den
sommerurlaub auf long island heißt es
dann wohl dieses jahr bei alarm statt
high society
[Musik]